I noticed a lot of people were asking
for experiences and it really got me
thinking about kind of this Instagram
era we kind of said oh well wouldn't it
be fun to get a bunch of artists and
creatives together and kind of do this
color experience color Factory is a
12,000 square foot color experience if
you've ever seen an installation like
the rain room or the infinity mirrored
room you know that social media can play
a huge role in how we experience and
interact with art now some creators are
flipping the script with a new category
of installations made for Instagram
these exhibits take the design language
structure of a traditional Art Museum
and add details like perfect lighting
colorful backdrops or interactive props
they're all translate really well to
photos on social media we can make a
beautiful photo that will do very well
on the internet but it was really
important to me that color factory was
more than that I kind of came down to
three characteristics that I wanted each
exhibit to have ideally one is I wanted
it to be something that you normally
didn't get to experience so whether
that's laying underneath you know 100
pounds of confetti falling down on you
or you know walking through a room full
of ribbons
the second characteristic is we wanted
it to have a concept behind it not to be
just a pretty picture but you know that
there was some thought and some meaning
and then the third characteristics is we
want it to be really photogenic so we
did want it to be make a really good
Instagram and there was a few decisions
we had to make like even with lighting
where maybe a warmer light would have
felt better to like be there but a wider
light looks better hunt Instagram so
what's the difference between a space
like this and say the rain room well
some would say there isn't one the way
we experience art today is in many ways
through our phones but others would draw
a distinction between an installation
where an artist has explored space light
and scale and mood in interesting ways
and something like the color factory or
the Museum of ice-cream which is
designed to be reproduced on Instagram
as much as it is meant to be enjoyed in
real life we're not a traditional Museum
I never I would never set out to me I
think that people come one gets stuck on
a title or a name you come and you have
this experience the museum lives on in
so many different verticals and ways and
were a brand
I kind of wanted to juxtapose what
people think is a traditional Museum and
put artifacts and paintings in and give
that kind of sense that you would expect
and then take you into something that's
far more imaginative if you look at
traditional museums they exhibit art
culture they bring people together for
specific meaning they celebrate design
they celebrate history all of those
things we as a company equally share
there's been this traditional sense of
you know the ropes and everything is
something that you stand and you're an
observer but you're not an active
participant the Museum of ice-cream
welcomes and celebrates the interaction
of our visitors with the art and
installations there's a question is this
art
I don't know I'm not gonna be the one to
say if it's art and we brought on a lot
of talented artists to work on this it's
interesting to see like I go to the SF
MoMA and everyone was just trying to get
instagrams you know like is that what
art is becoming is like what you're
experiencing and sending out into the
world I don't know I just think it's
interesting and that's the reality of
the world we live in right now I don't
think that social is what is driving
what the museum ice cream does I think
about how people feel like what is that
actual experience I design it not for
those little like uncleís or vignettes
if you will that is very much dictated
by our visitors that come and they be
able to create what are those moments
for themselves
we don't say hey this is your moment to
take a photograph I give everyone a
canvas and it is their opportunity to
make it one day well
whether you're in a space like the
museum ice cream or the Museum of Modern
Art you're going to find people looking
at exhibits through their thumbs the
question isn't necessarily is that okay
or whether social media has transformed
or produced art but what can you get out
of these spaces is it an experience that
makes us think and reflect and see the
world differently or is it an experience
that amounts to that little square photo
you post online
I'm really proud of it and what it
turned into and a lot of people are like
how are you making money from this and
I'm like like you know at our core we're
a bunch of artists and creatives and
that's we just want to create these
magical moments so hopefully you know
make as many people as happy as possible
I see Museum of ice cream 1 2 & 3 which
were sitting in three today as Vitas
I've always thought it was that I think
that people often experiment whether
it's in a lab or a different place in a
prototype it just so happens and my
prototypes have hundreds of thousand
people that go and experience it
[Music]